Community Pride on Las Vegas now is
sponsored by Findlay automotive group
Southwest Medical part of Optum care
Silver State Schools Credit Union and NV
Energy
[Music]
is a proud Community partner and is a
sponsor of the 22nd annual Las Vegas
June teeth Festival being held on
Saturday June 17th from 4 to 9 at the
expo at World Market Center Las Vegas
and joining us to tell us more is NV
Energy director of communications Angel
Williams and Diane Pollard the founder
of the Las Vegas Juneteenth Festival
welcome you to thank you it's so good
I'm so excited about this event it
sounds like so much fun let's talk to
you first Angel tell us why it's so
important for Envy energy to be involved
in an event like this at NB energy we
like to say the power of good is always
on and how we activate that is through
Community sponsorships like the one that
we enjoy in partnering with the
Juneteenth Festival and this is an event
that is really important Diane tell us
why it's so important well it's
important because it's a fabric in the
African-American Community but it's a
festival that we open up to the whole
community of Las Vegas and that's being
a part of the community and asking the
community to come in and celebrate this
wonderful thing that happened so long
ago and to help Empower
small businesses and some large ones it
just makes it great because we can work
with so many children like our
foundation does and it's just a
wonderful family event there's vendors
there's food trucks there's so much
going on and there's so much to learn
what do you both want people to know
about juneteen what is important for for
the public to know and the energy
Foundation enjoys supporting this event
because it's a wonderful way for us to
extend that education out into our
communities and with our customers it's
another great way for us to engage our
employees so we have a lot of employees
volunteering their time at the Festival
this weekend I'm sharing our Energy
Efficiency information but also
supporting the good work that the
festival does it really sounds
incredible what are people going to find
there well when they come it's going to
be free it's great parking it's on the
inside uh there's going to be things
there for kids to do there'll be
giveaways there'll be vendors from all
walks of life and we're just excited
because the whole valley participates
and we're looking for a big crowd of Jay
Haywood has worked very hard and I want
to say his name so that everyone knows
the work he's done we've got our own 702
from Las Vegas artists and they're going
to be there yes
enjoy the festival you know we've been
working with uh people on the strip and
all over uh to get people to come out
and are we're so excited and we're just
we can't wait it really does show how
far the African-American Community has
come since the end of slavery and what a
wonderful thing to celebrate thank you
both so much for joining us thank you
coming up let's